six one seven eight three zero 47 50 why
don't we try the 469 area code let's go
to our next caller from four six nine
where are you calling from um hello
hello you're on yeah okay great hi I'm
Sean I'm calling from Texas the great
big old state
great what's on your mind Sean um so I
know like we just have two other
Pennsylvania a special election last
night and that's had me really excited
but also kind of intrigued because the
candidates that ran in that race was a
lot more of like a like a blue dog kind
of candidate I mean I've heard that from
some on the right but he's for marijuana
legalization he once said yeah there he
was against Trump's yeah yeah but but it
was interesting because like okay so I
think the kind of what they're basing
that off of is like how he tried to get
himself to be like perceived by the
voters by the electorate there so like
if you see any this campaign stuff you
like really pushing that he's a veteran
and he is like you know because there's
this kind of maybe just perception on
the right that veterans are all
Republicans or something so yeah he
tried to push that to the electorate
there but um in a way I was intrigued
because the because it went phenomenally
well for the Democrat I mean it was a
20-point swing it's in line with our
special election swings which is an you
know danger for Republican because I was
interesting asking you what do you think
is best for the Democratic Party right
now coming into the midterms like the
real heat of it is it the path of going
with like a more a candidate that's more
like DCCC backed and like you know or is
it better to go with the candidate
that's very local you know like a like a
Connor Lam oh yeah this is a very good
question there is no one answer if this
is what and in fact it exposes what
Democrats should not do do not look or a
solution that will
work everywhere right in some places one
type of candidate will be much better
than the other and in the end
deshaun it will come down to one thing
which is turnout that's the thing it
doesn't matter whether it's a blue dog
or a d-triple-c a joe manchin type of
Bernie Sanders type whatever haha if the
if the turnout is not there because it's
pathetically low in midterm elections
often it's not gonna matter what
Democrats are gonna get quat well that's
the crazy part because it's been
phenomenal for Democrats in the midterms
right now I think I was looking at the
data yeah and don't do that that's the
problem don't don't look at because the
problem is people are looking at it and
they're saying exactly what you're
saying to Sean it looks fantastic and
that gets people not to vote you know oh
no yeah I don't know you know anything
that's really like this happening down
here in Texas but Laura Moser down in
Houston there's been a lot of
controversy because the DCC right please
backing this other candidate and
actually actively campaigning against
the Laura you're on a swing district
that they need to win and a lot of the
people that at least I can see on social
media and such are behind Laura a lot of
the local people that are going to vote
that lives there and it's kind of crazy
so yeah I'm just you know just gauging
that you know like is it what you know
what is a national you know party what
the National Party is going to do for
that but if there's that as a result
from the election like what is your
outlook look limited terms like from
based off of this house my outlook is in
pre we got to get out there and vote and
I'm not gonna say anything about how the
generic ballot looking cuz that can only
help to get people to stay home it's
gonna be an uphill battle is my point
yeah and we all gotta go go alright to
Sean thank you very much appreciate it
we will take calls again I know there's
more than a dozen people holding
unfortunately that's just all the time
we have today but we will take calls
again that I promise you and we've got
more audience questions coming up after
the break